всё что вы делаете неэффективно Пока вы
Не найдёте свою точку приложения усилий
поверьте сколько бы сил вы не вкладывали
результат всегда будет ниже ваших
ожиданий Если вы тратите время и энергию
не на точку приложения усилий А ведь
можно же было делать меньше и достигать
большего хотите узнать как сегодня мы
поговорим о том как найти точку
приложения усилий которая даёт
максимальный результат при минимальных
усилиях досмотрите это видео до конца и
я поделюсь с вами секретами которые
кардинально изменят эффективность ваших
действий Если вы не внедрить в свою
жизнь то о чём я вам сейчас расскажу то
вы всю жизнь будете двигаться по кругу
Давайте начнём с того что волнует
каждого из нас все мы заняты мы
перегружены делами обязательствами
бесконечными задачами Нас учат что чем
больше мы работаем тем большего успеха
мы добьёмся но это
Ловушка Как часто вы работаете
Изо дня в день но замечаете что
результата всё равно нет или результаты
небольшие большинство людей вынуждены
признавать что все их старания приносят
лишь незначительный Прогресс И кстати
есть различные техники Как убрать
фрустрацию прокрастинацию лень а о них я
расскажу в одном из своих следующих
видео поэтому подпишитесь на мой канал
чтобы это видео не пропустить А бывают
ситуации когда вы вроде бы сделали так
небольшое усилие А результат восходит
все ваши ожидания Бывает такое
Поделитесь в комментариях о таких
случаях почему так происходит Почему не
все наши действия дают одинаковую отдачу
почему несмотря на все советы учёбу
книги
Подкасты мы не можем достигнуть того
чего хотим Почему другие подходы не
работают Давайте разбираться причина
здесь проста дело не в количестве усилий
а в том куда мы их прилагаем вам часто
говорят Надо работать больше работать
нужно усерднее там но мало кто говорит
там работай умнее и это Ключевое как
говорил основатель компании Apple Стив
Джобс работать нужно немного работать
нужно с умом Я часто вижу как успешные
предприниматели застревают в рутине
пытаюсь успеть всё и сразу но в
современном мире выигрывают не те кто
много пашет а выигрывают те кто умеют
сконцентрироваться на главном и
отбросить всё ненужное заметьте повторю
здесь кто умеет во-первых А
сконцентрироваться и Б на главном
Давайте приведу вам пример один из моих
учеников он достаточно успешный
бизнесмен чей бизнес уже приносил
неплохие деньги но он чувствовал что всё
он как бы стоит на месте что его рост
замедлился он тратил очень много времени
на то чтобы совершенствовать свои
действия которые он Ну как он думал
приведут большим результатом когда мы
сели и разобрали с ним его ежедневные
задачи то оказалось что 80 Я утрирую
примерно 80% его усилий уходит на
абсолютно неважные вещи Что значит
неважные Вроде вы скажете бизнесмен у
которого хороший Вроде бизнес как он не
может такие вещи даже регулировать
почему он занимается неважным делами
смотрите это не значит что он занимался
ерундой Нет это значит что он тратил
очень много времени на выполнение зада
которые не давали большого эффекта сами
по себе задачи были конечно же важны но
проблема была в том что он должен был
заниматься не ими И кстати это основная
беда всех людей мы всё время стремимся
заниматься важными делами без учёта того
как эти дела влияют на эффект Проблема в
том что все люди по-разному понимат Что
такое важное дело так вот важным
смотрите важ
только такое дело выполнение которого
даст вам 80% результата на ваши 20%
усилий всё остальное нужно делегировать
или попросить сделать другого так вот мы
с моим учеником сели и выделили Ту самую
точку приложение усилий это ключевые
моменты на которые Ему нужно было
сконцентрировать все свои усилия в
результате за 3 месяца он удвоил свой
доход И это без увеличения нагрузки на
него я даже скажу больше нагрузка
немного
снизилась особенно на его печень в чём
конкретно была его проблема Давайте я
вам расскажу Дело в том что его бизнес
был завязан в основном на выполнение
заказов крупных компаний соответственно
80% своих усилий он прилагал на то чтобы
ублажать своих крупных клиентов он
дружил с ними ходил в баню ездил в
отпуск с ними Проблема была в том что
его внимания хватало только на
ограниченное количество клиентов и таким
образом он сам являлся узким горлышком
своего бизнеса он не мог наращивать свой
бизнес дальше Потому что его не хватало
на всех он думал о том чтобы обучить
своих замов работе с важными клиентами
но в то же время он боялся что они могут
создать свою компанию и увести его
клиентов поэтому он был в такой ловушке
с одной стороны бизнес большой хороший
вроде бы Аа и он считал что держать
связь с крупными клиентами - Это
основное важное дело которым он должен
заниматься но в тоже время он сам
являлся ограничителем в своём бизнесе и
вот когда мы разобрали его бизнес мы
определили и поняли что ему нужно
сконцентрировать свои усилия на бренде
компании и на создании отдельного
подразделения для работы на розничном
рынке Потому что его товар можно было бы
спокойно продавать на розничном рынке
Просто он был неуверен в этом а
отношения с крупными клиентами Он должен
был передать своим партнёрам не зам
таким образом точка приложения усилий
была совсем не в той плоскости в которой
он думал как это работает смотрите в
любом деле или процессе есть 20% задач
которые дают 80% результатов это Принцип
Парето Наверняка вы его слышали или
знаете так вот самое важное при
выполнении любого дела понять где
находится эти 20% чем чаще Я сталкиваюсь
с успешными людьми тем больше я
убеждаюсь в том что они интуитивно
понимают Где находятся те 20% которые
дают максимальный результат оставайтесь
со мной до конца и я расскажу вам о трёх
способах определения точки приложения
усилий которые перевернут ваше
представление об эффективности Итак как
же найти свою точку приложения усилий
дам вам три способа для трёх случаев
Итак Способ первый Если Вы только
начинаете какое-то дело то обязательно
выявите ключевой фактор успеха или то
без чего успех в этом деле труден или
невозможен Что такое ключевой фактор
успеха в любом деле или процессе есть
ключевой фактор успеха это фактор
который прямо влияет на ваши шансы
достичь успеха или результата заметьте
фактор который влияет на ваши шансы
потому что между вашим решением и
результатом этого решения всегда есть
шансы так вот там вам нужно найти
ключевой фактор который максимально учит
ваши шансы выявление ключевого фактора
успеха и будет вашей точкой приложения
усилий в начале любого дела Поверьте мне
это непростое дело после того как вы
выявили ключевой фактор успеха вашей
точке приложения усилий будет выполнение
ключевого фактора успеха или направление
ваших усилий на максимизацию шансов
достижения результата или усиления этого
ключевого фактора успеха Если вы
например открываете магазин то для него
ключевым успеха будет локация с высокой
проходимостью соответственно направьте
лучше 80% своих усилий на поиск хорошей
локации А 20% на всё остальное В то
время как ваша команда может работать
наоборот
20% направлять на поиск локации А
80% на выстраивание работы самого
магазина кафе или ресторана Или например
Вы если вы хотите покушать в зависимости
конечно от вашего голода для вас
ключевым фактором успеха
ближайший открытый ресторан
соответственно направьте все ваши усилия
на поиск такого а не на просмотр
рейтингов и отзывов о ресторане Если вы
хотите понравиться кому-то то для вас
ключевым фактором успеха будет
количество внимания которые вы уделите
этому человеку а не то что вы ему
сообщите проблема многих заключается в
том что они концентрируются на свом
сообщени способ второй
вы хотите Но не можете вырасти в бизнесе
или карьере то точка приложения усилий
для вас будет выявление И нахождение
вашего узкого горлышка или того что
мешает или ограничивает ваш рост это
тоже непростое дело Именно поэтому сюда
Нужно направлять 80% своих усилий А если
вы нашли узкое горлышко то точки
приложения усилий у вас уже будет
загрузка расшивка или обход этого узкого
горлышка Ну вот как например с моим
учеником о примере которого я
рассказывал вам ранее Если вы хотите
решить проблему то направьте 80% усилий
на выявление корневой причины и далее
уже решайте её выявление корневой
причины - это самое сложное но в то же
время самое эффективное в решении любой
проблемы поэтому направьте все усилия
туда после решения проблемы направьте
80% усилия на то чтобы такие проблемы
больше не повторялись Как вы видите
точка приложения усилий всё время
меняется и нужно чётко понимать где она
это и называется работать с умом эта
тема в целом большая и требует не только
одного видео для того чтобы глубоко
разбираться в таких вещах вам нужно
развивать эффективность своего мышления
вообще в целом развитие эффективности
мышления должно стать основной точкой
приложения усилий любого человека и то
что вы смотрите это видео говорит о том
что вы понимаете и то что вы находитесь
на правильном пути Поэтому всегда
помните что всё самое важное и ценное в
жизни строится на понимание того куда
направлять свои силы Если вы научитесь
этому вы не только добьётесь успеха в
бизнесе но и обретёте баланс в своей
жизни желаю вам успехов на вашем пути
Пусть ваши усилия всегда приводят к
максимальному результату Если вы хотите
больше узнать об эффективной жизни я
создал пространство Где собраны все мои
знания инструменты и размышления это
пространство для активных людей которые
хотят развиваться и где они будут
поддерживать друг друга Если вы готовы
продолжить свой путь саморазвития вместе
со мной то ссылка будет внизу